I'm Kristen O'Keefe afterwards and this
is three months after the one to
disappear is different from wanting to
die to disappear it's not have to
explain to anyone to talk to anyone to
move to somewhere where no one knows you
where you don't have to look at a single
laughing face to elope with this grief
who is not your enemy this grief who
maybe now is your best friend this grief
who is your husband the thing you curl
into every night falling asleep in its
arms who wakes up early to make you your
cold thankless breakfast to go to that
place where every surface is a blade a
sharp thing on which to hang your sorry
flesh to feel something
anything other than this
[Music]
for an interview with the poet watch
this video or check out the next poem in
this series